[Musique]
l'entrée du château de selles sur cher
un site plutôt bien conservé mais à
l'arrière le domaine s'abîme
considérablement notamment au niveau des
cheminées médiévale les cheminées du
xviie siècle menace de s'effondrer parce
qu'elles ont été entamées par le temps
le tuffeau a été rongé par les
intempéries sur quatre siècles et
aujourd'hui elles menacent de
s'effondrer sur le toit alors l'objectif
est clair il faut les remettre en état
seul problème la restauration coûte très
cher du coup le collectif qui milite
pour la sauvegarde du site a eu une idée
pour sauver le ses deux cheminées on a
décidé de lancer une campagne de
financement participatif
parce qu'il y avait une urgence puisque
l'hiver dernier une des pierres des
cheminées est tombé dans le groupe car
l'objectif punch mines et il faut qu'on
il faudrait qu'on récupère 14000 euros
dans un premier temps au moins pour la
première
ensuite il faudrait qu'on aille jusqu'à
25000 euros pour la deuxième chez nous
financer les travaux d'un monument privé
par le biais d'un financement
participatif n'est pas un problème pour
le propriétaire du site plutôt une
aubaine donc il faut échafaudé toute
cette partie je pense précisément que
c'est l'opportunité que nous avons nous
aussi privé pour pouvoir lancer des
rénovations et autres parce que on est
un site patrimonial dont nous sommes
classés monuments historiques
à ce titre nous sommes patrimoine de la
ville de celle de la région de toute la
france à titre au même titre que
d'autres monuments historiques et le
fait de participer à une campagne comme
celle ci est bien c'est contribuer à son
propre patrimoine également au delà des
cheminées c'est tout le château qu'il
faut préserver un site important pour le
tourisme local faut savoir que ce
château a en l'espace de 3 4 ans triplé
ses entrées et ensuite surtout à
pour cette année atteint presque 5000
visiteurs étrangers
il y a donc urgence à entretenir le site
en attendant les travaux sur les deux
cheminées débuteront en janvier à terme
elles seront remontés à l'identique
comme au xviie siècle